this weekend the start Finish Line at
the Southpoint 400 is going to look a
little different and it's all in honor
of breast cancer awareness now earlier
in the week I was at Las Vegas Motor
Speedway the sponsors of this next
segment for the story behind this
special cause
all right Chris paint the line pink what
a special day tell us more about this
event well as soon as we found out that
our NASCAR weekend was going to be in
October we knew we wanted to do
something in association with the
American Cancer Society and with breast
cancer awareness and we had some very
creative employees who came to me a few
months ago and they said well now that
we're in October we've got to do
something special we got to do something
in pink and a little did I know it was
going to be the start Finish Line but
when they came up with that idea and we
got NASCAR's approval I thought what a
great statement we can make to race fans
and for people who have been affected by
breast cancer and hardly anybody has who
is out here today we had Ryan brownie
from the South Point Hotel Casino and
Spa in Ronnie Ryan is the general
manager of the south point so Ryan was
here helping us paint as well as Noah
Gregson who competes both in the Xfinity
series he's from Las Vegas and this
weekend he's going to race for in the
cup series for his first time in Las
Vegas oh it's great to be here
supporting the breast cancer drivers and
you know patients everybody who's been
affected through breast cancer to be
able to paint the star Finish Line pink
when you cross the finish line this
weekend will be this be the first ever
finish line that you cross that you
painted yeah yeah they might have to
touch up my lines I was always pretty
good at coloring in the lines but I'm
not too good at painting someone's
watching right now and maybe struggling
right now with breast cancer and stuff
what kind of words of encouragement do
we have for that for that person right
now you know what the initial diagnosis
really sucks and the whole process is a
pain but at the end
you feel so good that you know it's done
and you're over it and you know for me
it was 10 years ago it was and I'm 10
years cancer free wow right and so
foreign
[Music]
got an official flyover well I'm here
with Gail who flew in from Florida for
this special day and and breast cancer
has had a big impact on your family can
you tell us more we have
four first cousins right now
who are survivors
my mom was a victim her sister was a
Survivor this is something that's near
and dear to us I can't begin to tell
people though
the one three word you never want to
hear is you have cancer
but through these organizations we're
able to say there's still hope encourage
early examinations the brothers in the
house that prostrate cancer is one that
you must must take seriously it's not
just breast cancer
this is something that affects any and
everyone Childhood Cancer is something
that'll bring tears to your eyes but
when you see a child that survived
bald headed yesterday and having flowing
hair tomorrow that's what you live for
so many special stories out there at the
track and we're giving you a chance to
go to the NASCAR races this weekend be
caller eight right now at
702-792-8801 to win two tickets to
Saturday's alsco uniforms 302 and two
tickets to Sunday's South Point 400 race
you will need to make an account on
lvms.com if you win so good luck and
start dialing also